good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight christmas
is almost here the best week on the
american calendar the happiest time that
we have
this year of all years christmas has a
deeper resonance maybe closer to its
original meaning
in a time of crisis you inevitably start
thinking about those things you
otherwise might ignore
if you were busier and more content
things like
what's the purpose of all of this what
matters most
in my life and what happens when it ends
in general people tend to become more
spiritual more openly religious
when they're suffering it's not an
accident in fact it may be the upside
you get to think beyond the next amazon
delivery for a minute
of course not everyone is in favor of
that all the focus on the big
enduring things the focus on our
families the focus on what's true and
what's not true
the focus on eternity itself all of that
tends to diminish the power of the
people in charge of our temporal world
for obvious reasons we take our leaders
less seriously
when we're reminded that they're just
people slightly ludicrous just like we
are
when we're reminded that they too will
pass all of us
will if death is inevitable that may be
the one thing you're not allowed to say
in this country but it's still true
that maybe we should pause before we
destroy the living
in the name of trying to eliminate it
politicians understand this threat
they've figured out that christmas is
bigger than they are
and therefore it's a threat to them
better cancel it in fact they're trying
hard
out of minimizing travel to the extent
possible sometimes
it's absolutely necessary but to the
extent possible
don't travel don't congregate together i
know
how difficult that is right now that's
just should not be done
to the best of our capabilities we
should avoid travel and avoid
congregates
avoid congregate settings
so say what you will about tony fauci he
has mastered after many decades
the weird euphemisms of washington dc
what fauci is saying here in english is
that you need to avoid going to church
you need to avoid your own family those
the congregate
settings he just mentioned you need to
spend christmas alone
it's important all the experts agree
with that the centers for disease
control sent that very message this week
the cdc's incident manager a man called
dr henry walkey
declared that quote the best thing for
americans to do in the upcoming holiday
season
is to stay at home and not travel so
skipping christmas is
the best thing says dr walkee you should
know that dr walkey is a product of the
johns hopkins bloomberg school of public
health
and those you may remember are the
people who just this summer were
publicly encouraging blm
to riot in our cities on medical grounds
needless to say
one senior scholar at the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health
someone identified as dr jennifer nuzzo
who by the way does not appear to be an
actual physician but does boast
that she's a climate activist tweeted
this memorable piece of epidemiological
guidance
back in early june here it is quote in
this moment
the public health risks of not
protesting to demand an end to systemic
racism
greatly exceed the harms of the virus
in other words in her studied expert
medical opinion
not looting macy's failing to burn down
businesses you don't own
is actually more dangerous than getting
the coronavirus
now you're a civilian that might sound
crazy to you but again you're not an
epidemiologist
they know better the former head of the
cdc himself
dr tom frieden endorsed that guidance
so there's a consensus here all the
experts agree the things
they like are perfectly safe indeed
encouraged
but the things they don't like are
deadly catastrophic
in fact listen to joe biden explain how
many americans will die
if we don't cancel christmas we're
likely to lose another
250 000 people
dead between now and january
you hear me because people aren't paying
attention
you hear me 250 000
americans dead you hear me a quarter
million people that's a lot of people
in fact it's more than the total number
of combat deaths over the entire
american civil war which by the way
lasted four years
condensed into a single month imagine a
gettysburg
every day of the week you can't imagine
that it's too horrible
in the first 30 days we would lose the
equivalent of reno
the next month scottsdale then lubbock
then buffalo
pretty soon there would be nobody left
in america you hear me come on man
do what you're told cancel christmas or
at least stop
walking walking is now an unpatriotic
act so is bicycling and any contact with
wheeled vehicles
that's the word from los angeles los
angeles our second largest city
has just issued a new corona law it bans
quote
all travel including quote travel on
foot
bicycle scooter motorcycle automobile or
public transit
all of it in los angeles movement itself
is now illegal sorry kids public health
emergency internal passports are on the
way
in the meantime though you've got
netflix and weed so stop complaining
in case you're confused by this guidance
eric garcetti would like to make it very
simple for you
eric garcetti is the mayor of los
angeles that's his title
anyway but over his years in office
garcetti's role has grown
he now wields powers we once associated
with enver hoja of albania
and certain ancient phoenician gods eric
garcetti may
seem like a garden variety elected
official oily
incompetent not yet 50 years old but
that's an illusion
in fact eric garcetti is omnipotent
watch my message couldn't be simpler
it's time to hunker down it's time to
cancel
everything and if it isn't essential
don't do it don't meet up with others
outside your household
don't host a gathering don't attend a
gathering
it's time to cancel everything commands
lord garcetti and when he says
everything he means everything
up to and including your most sacred
holiday time with your family
the illusion of free will itself you
were a citizen
now you are a supplicant in all it took
was a single sentence
from eric michael garcetti a pandemic
like this confers such powers
london breed understood that very early
breed is the mayor of san francisco
elected apparently on the strength of
her fascinating name she has no other
obvious qualifications
on october 30th this year london breed
declared that the holidays
are super spreader events she delivered
the sad news
that we can't celebrate anything this
year
what we've seen during holidays sadly
is an uptick in the number of cases
because people are choosing to come
together
and sometimes these parties and these
events and these gatherings
they could become super spreaders it
just takes one person who is infected to
infect
you know all of the people who attended
a party even though this year will be a
sacrifice
the sacrifice is worth it
the sacrifice is worth it says london
breed now it's your sacrifice to be more
specific not her sacrifice
just eight days after making the
declaration you just saw
london breed was shoveling down some of
the world's most expensive food
at the french laundry restaurant up in
napa like governor
gavin newsom breed is terrified of the
dire public health implications of this
pandemic we're living through
sacrificing for
but she's not so concerned that she's
willing to endure any
personal inconvenience no matter how
small it might be no christmas for you
but london breed's got to eat and right
now london breed is in the mood for some
celery root manicotti
followed perhaps by the all-day braised
snake river farms beef cheek
310 apiece on the tasting menu the
sacrifice is worth it
steve adler understands sacrifice steve
adler is the mayor of austin texas
austin texas is a pretty great place
lots of people are moving there
it's one of the most charming cities
that we have if you've been to austin
recently you may have noticed huge
numbers of mentally ill drug addicts
crapping on the sidewalks and stealing
things and mugging people
steve adler did that steve adler wants
to make austin texas most welcoming to
the people who contribute
least and he's done that he's also
needless to say been extraordinarily
worried about
the coronavirus so worried that steve
adler has commanded his constituents to
stay home for the duration
he informed them this from a time share
in a mexican beach resort
he'd flown there secretly on a private
plane with a large number of people
he is not related to sounds fun but
don't try it yourself
steve adler might punish you here he is
and then we need to you know stay home
if you can
do everything you can to try to keep the
numbers down
this is not the time to to relax
yeah unless you happen to have a private
plane
headed to cabo otherwise stay home
that was mayor steve adler's message to
his people
delivered from the mexican beach resort
so what do we take from all of this well
it's
hypocrisy of course we point that out a
lot but it's deeper than that
the people giving us these highly
specific orders
don't believe the orders they don't
believe what they're saying
obviously they don't really think that
covid19 is very dangerous
if they thought it was very dangerous
they would be following their own
orders of course but they're not
following their
own orders nancy pelosi and dianne
feinstein for example are both over 80
years old
they're in the target demo they're at
risk and yet we know because it's on
video
that neither one is so worried about
covet 19
that she wears masks in private so what
does that tell you
it tells you everything and even slow
people like us are starting to figure it
out
last night there was a demonstration
outside a bar in new york called max
public house
no cases of chronovirus have been traced
to mac's public house
it's on a proven vector of transmission
as the epidemiologists say
so the owner of the bar refused to shut
down he wanted to live like
gavin newsom and london breed and nancy
pelosi he wanted to live like an adult
in america
unfortunately for him he expressed these
views out loud on television in fact
and that is definitely not allowed so
they arrested him immediately
and when they did a crowd of people
decided they'd had enough
stuff
[Applause]
you should know that no one from the cdc
or the johns hopkins bloomberg school of
public health endorsed the protest you
just saw
it was the wrong variety of politics and
therefore it was a serious health risk
to the nation not enough vandalism
apparently but we can expect more
protests like it
yesterday a small business owner in the
state of michigan called dave morris
interrupted a live shot on local
television
to make an increasingly obvious
observation about what we're seeing
and it's this the effects of these
lockdowns the sacrifices we're being
asked to make
are not evenly distributed across the
country
certain people a small group of people
seem happier than ever
you notice a certain self-satisfied
jauntiness behind their masks as they
bark orders at you
but everyone else is dying a slow death
dave morris joins us in a minute and he
can elaborate on his point but until
then one more question about all of this
and again it's an obvious one because
that's what we do obvious questions
if lockdowns work why haven't they
worked so far
we've been following increasingly
specific orders
all year don't travel wear math some
people
haven't obeyed but an awful lot of
people have most people because it's
america and people want to do the right
thing
and yet after almost a year of this the
numbers keep rising
so is the lesson really that we need a
whole lot more of what hasn't been
working
so far how does that work exactly